wir schauen uns einen satz an herr
altmaier da die erreger mit angela
merkel in die geschichte eingehen wird
an dem sie sich hat messen lassen und an
dem wir jetzt auch ihre kanzlerschaft
einmal messen wollen dass dieser satz
wir haben so vieles geschafft wir
schaffen das wir schaffen das und wo uns
etwas im wege steht muss es überwunden
werden ja wir schaffen das aber was hat
kanzlerin merkel geschafft julia
klöckner was hat nur merkel geschafft
was ist also ihre besondere idee gewesen
für deutschland ihre besondere leistung
die merkel leistung
jetzt ist sie so ist wie sie ist der wii
hat uns 16 jahre lang finde ich
hervorragend in der welt hätten wenn wir
uns mal anschauen wie sich
regierungschefs in anderen europäischen
ländern die klinke in die hand gegeben
haben welches chaos auch zu teilen in
anderen ländern hinterlassen worden ist
kann man bei uns wirklich sagen dass
zwar vielleicht etwas mit ja
unglamouröse sie hat sie ist uneitel und
legt auch nicht großen wert auf einer
entourage oder auch insignien sondern
prezi war immer wichtig es gearbeitet
wird dass man zum ziel kommt und ja
dieser satz wir schaffen das ich stelle
mir vor ein politiker würde sagen wir
schaffen das nicht dann kann er gleich
einpacken denken sie mal an die zeiten
der krisen eigentlich war jede
legislaturperiode mit irgendeiner krise
globalen krise auch belastet und das hat
sie wirklich mit einer ruhe und
beständigkeit ohne in hektische
polarisierung zu verfallen das hat so
macht einzigartig bisher ist das eine
frau aus der bundeskasse für die
frauenpolitik mehr gemacht als manches
frauenpolitische papier einfach durch
ihr seien dadurch dass sie gar nicht die
frauen frage gestellt hat sondern
dadurch dass sie als frau ihren job
gemacht hat und ihre frau gestanden hat
und gezeigt hat dass es nicht
ausgeschlossen kommt sondern wie man
reingeht und darauf ist auch eine
leistung auf klöckner aber mein mein
eindruck ist immer wenn wir über frau
merkel diskutieren so wie heute abend
dann kommt ganz viel was sie eben nicht
wahr also sie war da nicht eitel wird
pose tief gesagt sie hat sich nicht in
den vordergrund gespielt sie hat auch
die großen krisen irgendwie gemeistert
aber dass sein dass ein feld wie
wiedervereinigung kohl adenauer die
gründung der bundesrepublik ostpolitik
sie haben stabilisiert das kennen wir
das waren andere zeiten also ich meine
eine zweite wiedervereinigung kann es ja
nicht gegeben haben zum glück nicht aber
wir müssen sehr klar sagen sie hat in
der in der euro-krise in der finanzkrise
wenn wir uns diese diese
herausforderungen anschaut hat sie es
geschafft europa mit zusammenzuhalten
sie ist zielgerichtet und hoch
kompromissbereit und das ist die
grundvoraussetzung in einem europa
hat sie hat einfach die hand eines
geschafft und das kann man gar nicht
wenn ich in phrasen seiten beschreiben
nämlich dass man deutschland nicht nur
widerwillig respektiert weil das gute
autos baut und auch mal gute
fußballspieler hatte sondern weil das
man deutschland liebt deutschland hat
heute eine internationale sympathie und
anerkennung wie sie nie zuvor in seiner
geschichte in dieser frau merkel hat in
lausanne hat das deutschland geliebt
wird in der belziger und angela merkel
und angela merkel war eben weil sie
nicht in anspruch erhoben hat anderen zu
sagen wo es lang gehen muss weil sie
gesagt hat wir müssen anerkennen dass
auch die menschen in afrika das recht
haben auf ein menschenwürdiges leben
müssen ihnen helfen ihre solchen ihre
krankheiten zu bekämpfen weil sie
gemeinsam mit anderen
staats und regierungschefs bereit war
die kapitalmärkte die finanzmärkte zu
zähmen dadurch hat sie diese anerkennung
gewonnen und wenn ich als
wirtschaftsminister unterwegs bin mit
wirtschaftsvertretern und unternehmern
wir werden überall darauf angesprochen
und die leute haben uns in diesen 16
jahren um angela merkel wirklich
beneidet der diesel was ist ihr eindruck
was war angela merkels große idee
ja diese große idee habe ich nicht
festgestellt sie hat zweifelsfrei die
verdienste die meine vorrednerin und
vorredner schon dargestellt haben aber
sie hat auch sehr viel unterlassen sie
hat sehr viel nicht macht ich sehe diese
große idee nicht ich sehe auch nicht die
weltanschauung oder das lied ich will
mal sagen das lied das sie hat ich sehe
dass sie von tagespolitischen dingen
umzingelt ist und diese auch meisterhaft
gemeistert hat aber das ziel wohin sie
gehen wollt wohin die sie unser volk
führen wollte und das muss ein kanzler
haben das fehlt und ich glaube auch dass
die das ende ihrer kanzlerschaft
durchaus einen ein gespaltenes land ein
schwer gespaltenes land hinterlässt
nicht nur durch die korona frage nicht
nur durch die eingriffe die wir haben
auch die migration ist nach meinem
dafürhalten aus ihrem christlichen
politischen verständnis durchaus richtig
zu sehen aber völlig dilettantisch
umgesetzt
der bundesinnenminister die bundes in
strukturen haben völlig versagt man kann
ich 2,5 millionen menschen aufnehmen und
deren lebensinteressen vor den
sicherheitsinteressen von 80 millionen
deutschen das hätte viel geschickter und
klüger gemacht werden müssen ich sage
nicht dass die entscheidung diese wenn
es in not geratenen menschen sind diese
aufzunehmen war richtig die umsetzung
vatikan tisch und das ist für mich ein
umstand der auch heute noch eine große
zerrissenheit in unserem land darstellt
ganz kurz auf das auch nicht an weil
dann natürlich direkt mit angesprochen
sind wenn herr distel vor allen dingen
die flüchtlingspolitik die koordinierung
der
hier anspricht aber um frau glas zurück
in die sendung zu holen frau glas diese
spaltung die head distel gerade
anspricht hatte damit nicht recht wie
sehende tiefe polarisierungen der
flüchtlingskrise und auch jetzt wieder
in der korona politik das heißt das hat
frau merkel frage sozusagen nicht auf
der habenseite dass sie es nicht
verhindern konnte dass unser land
gespalten ist vielleicht sie selber zu
dieser spaltung beigetragen hat
ja ich glaube also das kann ich nicht
teilen weil du kannst nicht eine
kanzlerschaft an gehen und sagen ich
habe den plan und das mache ich jetzt
einfach sondern man fällt ja praktisch
jeden tag ist was neues ob das die
finanzkrise war es schon angesprochen
worden worden und die verschiedenen
krisen und ich würde auch 2015 nicht als
krise betrachten soll das war eine
katastrophe und die herren in europa und
sonstwo haben sich gedrückt sie nicht
entscheiden können dass sie was tun oder
dass sie vielleicht auch den hörer gar
nicht abnehmen oder dass sie
unerreichbar sind und ziehen musste und
hat gehandelt und dafür müssen wir jetzt
sehr dankbar sein und ich bin auch viel
in der welt unterwegs und ich höre immer
wie die menschen schwärmen und sagen sie
ist wirklich sie ist ein mensch die
seine frau wie sie verhandelt mit diesen
stolzen männern in anführungszeichen
will ich das sagen wie sie provoziert
wird wie sieht es ein steckt und ganz
bei sich bleibt konzentriert bleibt
nicht wütend wird und was ich ganz toll
finden dass sie eben eine bescheidene
frau ist dass sie als frau dee brachte
jetzt nicht was sie sich ihr wählen und
häuser und ich weiß nicht was ich glaube
dass sie ihr großes anliegen ist und war
dass sie europa zusammenhält und dass
sie deutschland da wo wir im mittelpunkt
sind hier einfach mit dem tut uns allen
versucht mitzunehmen und man kann auch
nicht von einer person entschuldigung
also ich finde das wahnsinn dass man
sagt sie ist jetzt das hat sie nicht
gemacht das hat sie nicht gemacht ich
finde sie hat eine tolle politik gemacht
sie hat immer wieder etwas so gefährlich
in vielen situationen dass du gedacht
hast um gottes willen was wie geht es
jetzt weiter und ihre ganzen telefonate
und ihre vielen reisen das habe ich zum
beispiel mit total befindet dann ist
sich schneller mal was ich in moskau und
am nächsten über den berg ist in
washington und so was alles das muss man
mal bewerten und darüber wird jetzt
nicht die stöhnt und ich kenne sondern
sie hat wie ich das nennen darf die
buben in schach gehalten weil ich möchte
mir nicht wissen man kann es ja nicht
sagen was gewesen wäre wenn da jetzt ein
auch ein macho dran wer hier bei uns in
deutschland oder ein machtmensch der
sagte setze ich jetzt durch mich ist es
ganz egal ich finde die angela merkel
eine hervorragende eine tolle frau und
ich lasse mir von niemandem sozusagen
klein reden weil sie eine in der welt
und ich freue mich mehr so dass die
leute sagen frau merkel und so das finde
ich einfach toll und es ist ja nicht die
gefühlsduselei warum so nehmen das
machen